il était de retour à chambord après cinq
siècles d'absence
les chevaux ont repris leurs droits dans
les allées et sur les parterres pour
célébrer une période capitale pour
l'équitation française à la renaissance
en fait en avons vient d'une équitation
italienne qui est extrêmement brutal
parce qu'on considère que le cheval
animal de dieu doit absolument
comprendre ce que lui demande l'homme et
si le comprends pas c'est qu'il ne veut
pas et les cavaliers français de la
renaissance
on approche de lire beaucoup plus
écologique on pourrait dire maintenant
c'est à dire que ils prennent le temps
d'acclimater d'accoutumée de caresser
d'utiliser les friandises de faire un
voilà un travail de fond de 500
cavaliers pas un de plus ont déambulé
sur un circuit de 13 km balisés
agrémenté d'animations et de panneaux
conçus spécialement pour ne pas mettre
pied à terre on voit plein d'époques
différentes de la renaissance à 1900
plein de costumes différents et puis
c'est très agréable de se balader sur le
site c'est très bien canalisé donc les
chevaux sont plutôt bien emmener ça va
plutôt bien
c'est ils sont étonnés ils regardent un
petit peu là le regard de la caméra mais
sinon ça se passe vraiment bien et c'est
vraiment totalement sécurisé et avec
cette chaleur pas question de laisser
quiconque se déshydrater les piétons
n'ont pas été oubliés avec des
démonstrations de dressage de haut
niveau pour les cavaliers le plus
compliqué a parfois été de trouver le
bon costume ça m'a appris à peu près
bonne cinquantaine d'heures et en plus
j'ai fait tout ce qui était un
harnachement du cheval donc j'ai bien dû
mettre 150 pour faire mon costume entier
cette manifestation a aussi inauguré la
route européenne d'artagnan quatre
circuits équestres qui permettent de
rallier chambord en passant par des
sites historiques